and one point lead is kept  by napolita and voting escaped by him  what did he escape  he didn't have to do the escaping no  farby did it for him  well  come on i mean he played this uh rookie  eight yeah it's true played something we  had to make some  good moves that's true actually king f7  i mean everything is hanging here  i have to calculate all this bishop f5  bishop d6 bishop f1  that is true  he is very slippery he's informed he  played quicker than fabi although he was  the side surprise in the opening  and here comes the perpetual  unless karanico's king d2  runs into 93 but that's not how he does  it  that's a nice trick  and he looks over and handshake  what a game to escape for fabi for uh  nepogi and how important i mean this  draw is equals right now with the  victory because he keeps the one point  lead  ahead of fabiano  and looks very satisfied  well  he looks very satisfied for sure he is  he must have  suffered in this game quite a bit